die malerei bereits 100 jahre den sie
als ausdruck von emotionen und
ereignissen und hat wichtige
geschehnisse für die nachwelt
unsterblich gemacht die sternennacht von
van gogh die mona lisa von leonardo da
vinci oder das letzte abendmahl vom
selben künstler haben sowohl im
zeitgeist konsumiert als auch deren
schöpfer unsterblich gemacht und so
wurde das bisher wertvollste gemälde
salvator mundi auch von leonardo da
vinci für unglaubliche 382 millionen
euro versteigert aber wie schwer ist
dass diese woche werde ich herausfinden
und damit den ikonischen malerei
tutorials von bob ross die in den 80er
und 90er jahren auch hier im deutschen
fernsehen ausgestrahlt wurden und dann
mein großonkel der tatsächlich künstler
war uns einiges an malerei bedarf und
vor allem künstlerisches interesse
vermacht hat werde ich das jetzt auch
probieren und begebe mich ins atelier
natürlich nennt diese die farbpalette da
okay das ist die farbpalette das ist
einfach so ein blog kann man jetzt
bleibt ihr blatt ab 10 theoretisch wenn
man mit blue flex da ich hier nicht der
erste bin der auf die idee gekommen ist
sich mit der malerei auseinander zu
setzen habe ich bereits leinwände
pinseln spachteln und öl farben von
meinem vater und nicht nur irgendwelche
sondern zufälligerweise auch die
originalen bob ross farben die gleichen
farben die er auch flüssig weiters
darauf das zeug hier aber wir kriegen
das jetzt drauf und wie viel davon der
erklärt ja nicht alles als es okay das
werkzeug habe ich alles gefragt ist
richtig ich bin richtig heiß dass ich
habe durch zufall seine seine box hier
gefunden haben perfekt meine sind nicht
mehr ganz so frisch aus aber wir tun ist
genau das habe ich auch mein gott drei
kinder zerstört weil sich das noch ganz
so flüssig ist wie das vielleicht vor 30
jahren mal war es gekauft wurde frau lu
qing vor
leven könnte sieht ein ganz anderes
mein gott mein erster gestartet
leider ein bisschen zu viel farbe war
sondern leidet hinweisen
beginnen sie das jetzt schon so krank
aus wer weiß mehr weiß ich habe wirklich
nur ein minijob verbot genommen jetzt
das mega pink ihr lebt man wird also
sehen dass wir ihm schon so krank aus es
sich bei mir aus wie sonst war es mir
kann man uns erst mal um diese
sprachliche eine große entscheidung wie
er das nennen würde
er macht jetzt noch mal so schön ist
meine flucht
wie sieht das denn aus beidem schon
wieder ich glaube das problem ist dass
ich von anfang an einfach schon viel zu
viel farbe drauf gemacht habe und jetzt
immer wenn ich mehr farbe drauf machen
will und ich auch wirklich will dass es
aussieht muss ich noch mehr weiß machen
damit kriegen die andere farbe ankämpft
und dann haben jetzt so eine suppe gut
muss passen
was wir jetzt nicht leider
jetzt werden quasi diese dinger in
reflektion vermieter und wenn man so ein
bisschen so ein wald sieht nicht sogar
das über dem aber es sieht okay aus in
der super league nächstes treffen wir
jetzt die wollen wir vor dem wasser ab
ich kriege die bäume gar nicht hin
der erste echte maria ein echter traum
einfach genommen
okay ich habe definitiv meine steigerung
haben hier direkt wieder im wasser das
ist zwar schon drauf haben allerdings
hier auch eine kleine kabine was ich
meinte natürlich eine camp in englisch
hier der kleine hütte und ein paar rote
töne zu dem himmel das nicht als gast
sondern gegangen und ich habe übrigens
immer noch nicht meine hände sauber
gekriegt dass es werde allerdings die
farben die ich gestern noch über
gelassen habe weil die sind echt noch
nie gut einfach noch mal angefangen
wieder mit dem guten alten liquid kuwait
und diesmal mit besonderem fokus auf das
ist schön gleichmäßig überall verteilt
wird
das wurde jetzt plötzlich blau ja es
gibt keine fehler es gibt keine
zufälle wfp existenz wir fangen mit geld
einfach hier in die mitte wo hat das
grüngut mistakes wfp existenz gehört
dazu ich habe schwierigkeiten die
richtige menge an farbe zu wählen damit
von außen rein und jetzt noch ein
bisschen wasser den berg
jetzt kommt das worauf ich mich schon
die ganze zeit fürchte und zwar eine
kleine pflanzen sind eine sache so grobe
dinge aber jetzt kommt wirklich eine
struktur
[Musik]
moment mal hat er geschummelt und er
macht hier eine tür genau wie ich und
mal da habe ich hier auch darüber
bewusst gemacht weiß zu machen wollte
und jetzt sagt er so wie schneidend ab
damit es passt dass es geschummelt
gutmanns geschummelt er hat jetzt
abgeschnitten aber hauptsächlich nochmal
drüber gemalt ohne unterlass davon zu
sagen der hund hätte ich gewusst dass
das nicht so leicht nicht so gemacht wie
er so wir haben hier schon fast unter
damit die tür nicht auffällt bruder bob
ross das war ganz schön viel arbeit
vielleicht habe ich sie morgen endlich
mal entweder mir einmal kittel an
zuziehen oder mein kollege schmutzig zu
machen
[Musik]
das bild das ich heute meinen wert ist
ein ähnliches wie das was ich schon mal
gemacht habe allerdings profis heute in
echtzeit mit dem alten meister zu malen
die anleitungen dauern immer ungefähr
eine halbe stunde ich habe selber drei
stunden gebraucht und ganz viel
pausieren müssen
die farben let's go schnell zeigt sich
mal mit an und ich lege los angeles
unterwegs und so den trick schon von
außen anfangen also noch richtig stark
[Musik]
er macht jetzt mit titanweiß wollten
es ist dies ist mekka klar wollten sind
fertig das ging ja fix ein kleiner berg
der macht auf einen spachtel
wie immer sind
so jetzt bisschen nebel meinte er müsse
aber jede farbe des kit mail.com crimson
jetzt background hier nicht sogar der
ist gut dass jetzt nicht so schön
geworden hier dann noch dicker baum
rechts oben hin okay
ganz mutige beim ok hier aber auch die
krainer werde ich ja es war ein
speeddating ich habe nur eine halbe
stunde zeit gehabt das ist es nicht so
mega geil aber ist es auf jeden fall ist
mein finger wieder dreckig wie sonst was
allerdings ist das bild fertig alten
herren mitgehalten nicht ganz perfekt
auch natürlich nicht so schön geworden
auch einfach eine gute lektion im thema
geschwindigkeit heute machen
[Musik]
heute haben wir mal ein bisschen ein
experimentelles hätte beim start mit
sondern sogar hier fällt draußen
aufgehen würde ich sagen er hat ein
eichhörnchen
wieso hat er dann aber es ist dann
selbst war schon dazu strom
[Musik]
es ist eigentlich recht dass farben
mischen
[Musik]
das wenn man blau und rot mischt wieder
rauskommt ist klar aber auf die idee
berge in lila zu malen wäre ich ohne
über bronze niemals gekommen
[Musik]
das lenkt ein schönes wetter zum
zeichnen nein es ist kompliziert als
nächstes machen wir noch hier ein paar
größere reduzierte räume ist ja der
hammer sagt die sonne ist verschwunden
genauso unserem bild eigentlich und das
ist auch genau so wie in diesem
verschneiten welt
ich tippe ich hab's das war eine ganze
andere experience weil einfach die
ölfarben sich natürlich bei diesen
niedrigen temperaturen ich glaube jetzt
mal so geschätzt 5 grad anders verhalten
natürlich viel härter sind nicht ganz so
weit sind wie bei raumtemperatur
irgendwas ist richtig geil geworden
richtig zufrieden mit dem himmel die
berge sind auch tropfte mega knocke
aller und das ist auch noch schick
geworden
diese ganze schneelandschaft nämlich
auch toll aber das hier das ding ist
hässlich in diesen worten bis morgen
bericht angekommen ist jetzt dieses
paket das ist einmal ausgesetzt was ich
damals schon hatte er nur halt viel viel
neuer der inhalt hat sich eigentlich gar
nicht geändert nur jetzt nicht alles war
trocken und kaputt und die pinsel sind
sauber ich will mich hier wie in der
bronx dauerwerbesendung ist es nicht das
ist mal wirklich flüssige flüssig weiß
und die ganze nacht farben und ihr sagen
damit und war noch mit diesem neuen
geruchlosen terpentin ersatz der
wirklich echt hoffentlich dafür sorgen
wird dass es nicht mehr so hart nach
gift stinkt holy moly dass die recht
flüssig das ist ja einfach komplett der
suppe ich bin ich mal nicht aber auch
wichtig mit neuen pinsel abermals über
nacht so soll das sein das ist wie milch
[Musik]
willkommen zurück ich dachte mir wir
machen heute eine wunderschöne
berglandschaft der kollege lässt sich
gerade die farben durchlaufen damit ihr
wisst genau welche farben wir verwenden
also warum nicht was heißt wir nehmen
selbst mal winzig bisschen ja ist es
blau und was soll es einmalig schönen
himmel drauf zimmern und wichtig immer
dem pinsel saubermachen industrie tue
dafür warum schmeißt man in schönenberg
reinkommen in halle sowie in crimson
großes stück verändert braun und nur den
kleinsten haupttableau es soll schön
flach auf streichen und zeigt diese
kleine rolle hier ne ecke die brauchen
wir ich mache mein berg ich schmerzen
hier rein ins wasser gehen wir schön von
außen nach innen und am ende einmal
schön drüber gehen und schon wenn damit
in der wunderschöne spiegelt ein paar
kleine bäume nehmen ein bisschen jetzt
krönt ein bisschen sap green van dyk
braun und taylor blue nehme ich mir
ausführen paar kleine bäumchen mit der
grund kleine bäumchen hier links passt
ein großer war eine schöne tanne ein
schönes ufer genau hierhin so ganz
kleine halbinsel hier ein schönes ufer
kommen wir jetzt mal ins dunkle grün ein
bisschen licht rein ordentliche ladung
gelb ein bisschen grün jetzt noch mal
ein paar so ein paar keine büsche darauf
ich habe den ganzen finden wir in etwas
für seine rettung
da nehme ich mir etwas schwarze farbe
die dadurch natürlich super super
flüssig und dünn wird und macht das
wichtigste die unterschrift ist da und
schon haben wir unser erstes fertiges
komplett alleine gezeichnet gemalt ist
gemälde ganz ohne borghorst komplett
ohne anleitung geben ich finds echt cool
ich finde sie keinen bisher und ein
richtig schön an für sich es ist schon
weh das gefühl jetzt einfach ohne
anleitung einfach so irgendwie ein
halbwegs brauchbares gemälde rauszuhauen
was allerdings unterschätzt wie er da
ist der rücken also meinen rücken vom
ganzen aufrechten stehen hier und sofort
tun wissen wer allerdings ist es
natürlich auch einfach gesund zu stehen
besonder also ganze zeit das sitzen also
in allem finde ich die malereien richtig
cool und ich möchte alles hier an den
ganzen set ab und an der staffelei und
zweitens von ein großonkel zu arbeiten
allerdings nicht dass ich das private
sehr häufig machen werde einfach weiß
echt viel arbeit ist und viel mehr
arbeit ist als zum beispiel mit
bleistift des hin und so freute
natürlich viel viel aufwendiger als ein
mob digitale konzern stellen ihr seht
gerade nochmal eine übersicht von allen
bildern ich gemalt habe genau in der
reihenfolge können ja mal gerne
reinschreiben ob ich mich irgendwie
besser tat ich finde persönlich ich war
von anfang an mit den anleitungen schon
halbwegs gut und die verbesserung war
jetzt gar nicht so krass da man einfach
schon von anfang an echt ok bilder macht
mit lausanne natation ich gehe jetzt die
patienten saubermachen und wünsche euch
noch ein wunderschönes wochen ach ja und
abonniert gerne signal und kann sich an
nichts wieder
[Musik]
one more time